hello hi how's it going guys I have been
live streaming on pretty much every
platform that I could possibly get my
hands on and I I have so much that I
want to talk about and hello I guys I
know it's late I'm really sorry about
that and I'll get to the point as
quickly as I can I've been making the
rounds on Instagram Twitter and Facebook
trying to refine down what I was saying
hey guys thanks so much for joining me
and chica is really tired but I'll get
her to bed soon yeah thanks guys
hey um I just wanted to say this is my
new office this is my new office I'm so
excited for this I like I can't even I
can't even explain how excited I am for
this because I've been working on
getting this thing set up throughout the
weeks since I got back from both the
tour and my hiatus and I've been working
on this since about eight or seven this
morning I can't I can't really explain
why but I've got my new set up here that
I'm gonna be making all my videos from
and I've got this room that some of you
guys and I don't know why why is it why
is it so washed out there but it's fine
I've been I've been so excited to be
able to make videos here and it's
finally here like it's finally here and
I don't know why I'm so washed out so
I'll just point it this way I guess but
it's finally here like I've been waiting
for this for so long and I've been
trying so many new things that you guys
have been so understanding with what
I've been doing and you guys have been
so like honest and open about the
feedback of what's going on and you guys
have been so accommodating for for
everything that we've been doing here
and I'm so like so unbelievably grateful
to you guys for allowing me to do this
and even chica because I want to I want
to first like explain exactly what's
going on here so this is the new office
that I'm gonna be recording all my
videos in and it's really cool and it's
super fun and it's really spacious and
I've got like these computers set up
here and I've got the monitors in the
livestream mode / doing let's play modes
and I've got a crazy webcam over there
and I've got my old computer that I
built like if you guys remember this I
was talking about this on the other live
stream but if you guys remember this
computer when I first came out to LA I
built this computer like this computer
here chicas scuse me you camera hog
you've already been in a video today you
came to being another one in this
computer here this was the first
computer that I came to LA with like I
built this myself in it I've upgraded to
here and there and you guys may have
noticed some of the Let's Plays recently
have been a little jittery and laggy but
even so like I built that computer and
I'm just like so incredibly excited to
see what the future holds because number
one like all this space here is for
virtual reality which I haven't been
able to do virtual reality video in ages
and hi guys thanks so much for joining
I promise I'll let you get to bed soon I
know a lot of you guys have been hopping
around like hoping then I'll say
something extremely interesting and
different than I've said before but
that's just not gonna happen but it's
it's just it's super cool and also like
I've got all this stuff set up to be
able to do live streams from here and
make better Let's Plays and also just
make generally the videos that I want to
make in the future and just have so much
cool content coming out of this stuff
that I have right here and I'm just so
excited for it I'm just so grateful that
you guys have been open and accepting
and understanding what I've been doing
and you guys have just allowed me to do
like what I need to do to be able to
find like these videos here because
everything that I've been doing and I
know it's been a little weird with like
the van vlogs and the the live stream
that I did yesterday and I said I was
going to do more and then I got a caught
up making this stuff and I know it's so
silly what we've been doing but at the
same time it's been so much fun like I
talked about this just his own Facebook
and I was doing a live stream and I
talked about it but it's honestly truly
so much fun like just to be able to do
is just to be able to do a silly video
with chica right here and be able to sue
a silly video work Oh Jacob help Jake
help me
just like that and I know it's so silly
like I know it's so silly just to do a
video like that but it's so fun like god
it's so fun it's so fun just to make a
video about going to Cracker Barrel it's
so fun to make who killed markiplier and
make something that's so unbelievably
like high quality for what I do it's so
fun to just buy a van and have the
entire fandom explode wondering if I'm
homeless like it's so fun and I really
do like if I had a point to make all
this and I promise that I'll make a
point out of this and stop wasting you
guys it's time here but if there's any
factor to take from this it's that when
I took a hiatus I wanted to come back
and make videos fun and I did and I'm so
close to I am so close because
everything is set up here and I've been
working since this morning getting that
set up there and I've been so excited
for everything that I've got going on
here and everything is just finally
coming together I'm just so incredibly
excited I'm so incredibly grateful for
you guys giving me an opportunity to do
this and I've been thanking you guys on
every single platform that I possibly
cannot have been talking about this just
because I'm so unbelievably excited for
it but sincerely thank you guys like
without you guys I wouldn't be even be
able to take the chance to do this and I
wouldn't be able to like take the
opportunities that I need to to figure
out what I need to do like it's so rare
that you know I've been doing this for
five and a half years now and at the
five and a half year mark I can come out
with a video and say like hey I kind of
not feeling this I kind of want to try
something new and I kind of want to like
figure something out for myself and and
be to be able to say then to be able to
do that and to be able to like take a
break from that and just make videos
that are fun like god that's such a rare
thing
and that's something that I'll always be
grateful for like no matter what happens
no matter where I go with my YouTube
channel
the fact that you even gave me the
chance and gave me a million chances
over because like a lot of you could
easily tell like I said this before but
you guys aren't stupid like you guys
know if something's up you guys know if
something's off you guys know if the
videos that I'm making aren't exactly
what they should be and if I owe you
guys anything it's that I owe you guys
the best that I can do and even if even
if the videos that I make are a silly
video of me with chica playing dead that
video is just so cute like it's so cute
I was working since this morning like I
got up this morning and I started
fiddling with this and then you know III
just wanted to make the video and I
called Amy over and I was just like hey
Amy I got to make a silly video do you
want to make a video where I kind of
play dead and chicas all crazy like that
and we just did that and then I saw it
and I was like oh my god I have to edit
this right away and then I immediately
did and that spontaneity like that
passion of it
the feeling of just making a video
because making videos is fun like that's
something that I can't get anywhere else
and it's something that I never want to
take advantage of and it's something
that's so incredibly important to me and
I owe every bit of it to you guys so to
glimpse the future I know I've got it I
had a point I met to come over here so
listen listen listen okay so I've got my
setup here I'm gonna be doing some super
awesome live streams here I've got
another computer over here so that
anyone who wants to join me on a live
stream can be right here next to me on a
computer say Amy comes over and we
wanted to do a live stream together
where we're playing with you guys and
doing some jackbox of playing some
zombie mode and pub G whatever we got
that hair I've got all this set up so I
can do Let's Plays right here I've got
all this set up all this space is for
virtual reality it's been so long since
I did a virtual reality video yes but
now I can do a virtual reality video and
I can even livestream it oh yeah the
washed out face really works for this
one I have no idea what it's doing that
I gotta get like this close to be able
to do that but you guys don't wanna get
that close to me but then I can even
like livestream virtual reality videos
and it's been ages since I've been able
to do a virtual reality video because I
just haven't had the space for it
like that's a crazy thing for me to say
and it's a crazy excuse but I just
haven't had the space for it and like
I've got my computer that I've had with
me since the beginning and then I got
this piece of new one that I didn't
build myself and I hate with a passion
that was terrible Oh awful but wasn't
it's it's all fine because I can see it
like I can see the new videos that I'm
gonna be making here I can see like the
potential that it has like it to show
case anything that I want to do I can
see where I'm gonna hang up all the cool
stuff that you guys are gonna give to me
like the van it's not all the videos are
gonna be about the van the videos are
gonna be about anything the videos are
gonna be about things that make me laugh
things that make you laugh things that
don't make you laugh and just make me
laugh and I look like an idiot like in
return but I can see all the things and
memories that I'm gonna collect and I
can see all the potential for new stuff
coming around the bend and I can see
every little detail coming out of it and
it's so exciting and so like I'm gonna
be doing ideally ideally if I was gonna
give you a sneak peak of everything and
listen closely ideally I would have a
mixture of gaming Let's Plays live
streams and sketches van vlogs
adventures just going out and being an
idiot doing things with chica the music
videos like schmoyoho just made which is
an amazing music video if you guys
haven't seen it it's fly like a
butterfly it's beautiful it's beautiful
and it's all combining and it's
something great that I haven't ever been
able to really do before but I haven't
ever really been able to be proud of
because I love making videos I really do
and when I went on hiatus like like I
said earlier you guys aren't dumb you
knew like you could tell that I wasn't
entirely the happiest person in the
world making videos at the point like in
the vlogs leading up to it I was trying
to I was beating around the bush of the
truth and then I came down to it
eventually and like it's just something
like it's something that was so obvious
and just hit me in the face I just
wasn't making the videos that I
wanted to make you know and that doesn't
mean no gaming that doesn't mean all
vlogs that doesn't mean anything that
means that the craziness that goes on in
my life is captured in the videos that I
make because the one thing that I owe to
you guys is being authentic and being
true to myself and being true to chica
because here's the most important thing
that I discovered in the time that I've
been going out and doing the van vlogs
in bringing chica with me she may not
seem in like not right now because she's
super tired like crazy tired she wants
to go to bed so badly I have never seen
her happier like I have never seen her
happier than when she was able to meet
you guys I've never seen her happier
than when she was able to be out there
with you guys and just hang out like
I've never seen her that happy in my
entire life like she's a happy bump and
obviously from the video this morning
whoa no my pillow what are you doing
okay all right well that's just how it's
gonna be then did you judging me you
judged me bubble but in the time I've
never seen her happier just happier to
be able to meet you guys and happier to
be able to be there with you guys and
happier to be able to be out and about
like it's something that I never even
knew it was missing until like we got
there and so if there's a point to this
and I'm not making any point that I
promised I was gonna let you guys get to
bed no promised I was gonna be out but
if the point to make is that I'm very
excited as you can tell to be able to
make content that I want to make to be
able to make Let's Plays to be able to
do live streams to be able to make van
vlogs to be able to make sketches to be
able to make things like who killed
markiplier and I can see it I can see it
all coming out in this front that's good
so anyway uh but that has to wait just a
little bit longer the most important
thing is I promised that I would go on a
vacation with the most beautiful girl in
the world and Amy had to literally
corner me and be like three months ago
Amy three months ago Amy cornered me and
was like okay I know you're busy so I'm
planning this way in advance like this
was back in August and she was like in
November
we're gonna take four days out for
vacation and this was so long ago that
we planned this but whose super it was
super sweet because she she knows Amy
knows that I I work all the time and Amy
knows that I'm always making videos and
Amy knows that my schedule is so crazy
but she planned ahead and so tomorrow
I'm the lucky guy that gets to go on
vacation with the most beautiful girl in
the world
and I want to make videos so badly
that's why I've been live-streaming
literally all night on every single
platform and I'm probably gonna cycle
through each of them again just talk
about how excited I am
but that's why like unfortunately and I
know it's weird to say unfortunately I'm
going on vacation but unfortunately I'm
gonna go on vacation and I'm not gonna
be able to make videos which sucks
because I'm ready and it's here and I
have everything I need and everything is
set up and I spent so long to set it up
and it's ready it's finally here
but I gotta go on vacation which is
terrible terrible the worst thing in the
world nobody likes vacation nobody likes
vacations but I won't be able to make
videos because I promised her that I
would take this vacation seriously and I
would not work while I was doing it so I
promise and I'm a man of my word and I
will keep my promise everybody knows how
strong a markiplier promise is and that
promise that won't be broken they're not
at all right chica even chica is sick of
my at this point but I got this
weekend and then after that things are
gonna be amazing
like really I I can't even understate it
like I I'm one to be hyperbolic and I'm
one to shout to the heavens about how
great everything is gonna be and
everything's gonna be wonderful but
let's play live streams virtual reality
live streams sketches like dramatic
things like who killed markiplier van
vlog silly like the video with
chica like the remix video like all
these great things just coming together
flute therefore power okay a little bit
I flipped it as hard as I could now I
got that Justin Bieber look but it's
great and I literally have
you guys to think because you guys you
guys you guys gave me an opportunity
that I never could have possibly
imagined you guys allowed me to take the
time I needed to figure out what I
wanted you guys gave me the opportunity
to like kind of rediscover the love for
making videos the the reason that I go
out and the reason that I work from like
6:00 this morning to now which is past
9:00 because I've been live-streaming
like a crazy person and I just want to
keep doing it I could do I gotta take
this vacation I've made a promise that
I'm gonna keep my promise but when I get
back I'm ready I'm so excited
and it's gonna be awesome so anyway I'm
gonna get out of here I'm gonna let you
guys go I'm gonna take you to bed I'm
gonna probably take you for a walk first
but just thank you guys honestly I'm so
excited for the future and I'm so
excited for what the future holds and
I'm so excited to go out there and see
you guys on Van road trips and and
sketches and little like impromptu
concerts in the back of my van I've had
this idea where like cuz I did the
acoustic set during the tour and I've
started really get into music and I want
I have this idea of making a video where
I just go around and like do like a
pop-up concert I had like crazy
like that anything this is so cool so
anyway thank you guys so much I'll let
you go I'll let you get to bed you guys
go ahead and get to bed I will stop
being crazy and I'll probably keep
live-streaming later on so just thank
you guys thank you for being here with
me through all this and thank you for
being just the most awesome fans I could
ever hope for so good night everybody
I'm out of here
I gotta take Sheik out she's so tired
and she's so Tucker so bye everybody bye
see ya after the weekend bye